pour écrire la présentation que je vous
présente aujourd'hui j'ai utilisé mon
ipad
cet objet n'est pas seulement mon outil
de travail mais représente également
pour moi une source d'activités ludiques
qui est ainsi qu un moyen de communiquer
avec mes contemporains
ce qui fait en sorte que je me
retrouvais souvent 30 minutes plus tard
à regarder des vidéos inutile sur
youtube et après avoir consulté qu'elle
soit mon compte instagram
j'ai fermé mon outil de travail en
prenez en promettant que j'allais être
plus productives lelangue
malheureusement je ne suis pas là fait
je ne suis pas la seule à faire si
régulièrement le trois quarts des
canadiens possèdent un téléphone
intelligent et 20 % d'entre eux le
consul plus de 50 fois par jour ces
chiffres c'est sans compter la
télévision les ordinateurs les tablettes
le montre que l'on le veuille ou non la
technologie est devenue une partie
intégrante de notre quotidien
l'internet est maintenant de ressources
que l'on trouve à volonté ce qui rend
difficile de s'en servir avec modération
désormais l'utilisation abusive la
technologie est classé au même titre que
n'importe quel dépendance
la différence avec les autres et ce qui
la rend encore plus dangereuse c'est
qu'alors que cod pendant son associé à
des profils d'individus particulier la
cyberdépendance pas affecter tout le
monde quel que soit l'âge le sexe ou la
situation socio économique la situation
je faisais exprès tout à l'heure il ya
plusieurs jeunes de mon âge qui la
subissent quotidiennement
en réalité ce comportement est tout à
fait normal puisque les applications
sont spécialement conçus pour me rendre
accro certains appellent ça le piratage
cérébrale quand on reçoit une
notification ou des like ton cerveau
produit de la dopamine qui est un
neurotransmetteur qui procure du plaisir
et de l'excitation à force d'être
constamment confrontés à ce type de
réaction ton cerveau l'anticiper sécrète
c'est un homme d'état prend un appareil
c'est ce phénomène qui cause des
comportements addictifs et ça les
compagnies le savent très bien
ils vont aller jusqu'à employer des
programmes en arrêt des spécialistes en
sciences cognitives et de la psychologie
pour arriver à maximiser cet aspect qui
nous rend si vulnérable ils y
parviennent en utilisant des algorithmes
qui s'adapte aux comportements pour nous
inciter à rester toujours plus longtemps
que les lecture automatique ou les
poteries fej
la cyberdépendance peut être associé à
une multitude de conséquences que je
n'arrive pas le temps d une humeur en 6
min pour les adolescents et même les
adultes on peut penser aux réseaux
sociaux et au problème de confiance en
soi qui en résulte on est moins souvent
à l'extérieur on est moins positif à
l'école ou au travail
on s'intéresse plus à notre présence
virtuelle qui à notre présence réelle
les enfants aussi sont m sont associés à
la technologie et c'est d un très jeune
âge aux états unis l'utilisation des
médias mobiles est passé de 39 80 % en
2011 et 2013 pour les enfants de 2 à 4
ans le problème c'est qu'au lieu de
s'inventer des jeux il pouvoir s'amuser
pendant des heures avec 13 syriens il
passe plus de temps ce divertir par des
images préconçues et des jeux déjà
inventé
bien sûr cela un impact fondamental sur
le développement de l'enfant
outre le fait de limiter les défis de
créativité imagination les heures
passées devant les et les écrans
augmente grandement la sédentarité
ces dernières années s'en vont la sts
est en augmentation exponentielle des
maladies comme l'obésité le diabète chez
les jeunes enfants
ceci étant dit la technologie comporte
tout de même des avantages considérables
en n'importe quel endroit dans le monde
on a accès à une quantité astronomique
de savoirs et de connaissances
notre créativité et nos idées peuvent
être exprimées d'une multitude de façons
et partager à des millions de gens en
quelques secondes
en fait le problème n'est pas la
technologie en tant que tel mais plutôt
l'utilisation qu'on en fait et pour être
capable de profiter des bienfaits faut
apprendre à s'en servir de façon
intelligente
il n'y a pas de solution miracle tout
part d'une discipline personnelle qui
est son lait
ac/dc la tête la première étape c'est
vraiment de prendre conscience de l'état
réel de notre relation avec les
appareils électriques dans certains
produits on nous indique notre temps
d'utilisation par jour ce qui peut être
un très bon outil si on prend la peine
de leur carte et ensuite on devrait
mettre en place des mesures pour nous
aider à parvenir à ses objectifs
par exemple certaines écoles au québec
ont commencé à interdire complètement
les téléphones cellulaires et ont
immédiatement remarqué des changements
très positif
de plus il n'y a pas juste les
internautes qui devraient faire des
efforts devraient avoir une meilleure
encadrent un meilleur encadrement des
entreprises ainsi qu'un design
réellement éthique des applications
certains ont déjà commencé à le faire
comme tristan harris qui a quitté son
poste à gogo pour fonder le center for
human technology un organisme qui milite
contre le piratage cérébrale finalement
si vous êtes les parents d'enfants en
bas âge
ne leur donnez petit c'est un écran dans
l'ue mais l'association canadienne de
pédiatrie recommande aucune exposition
aux écrans pour les moins de 2 ans et
moins d'une heure par jour pour les 2 à
4 ans bref la technologie ont un grand
impact sur le monde d'aujourd'hui et on
aura encore plus grand sur le monde de
demain
on n'a pas le choix on ne peut pas
revenir en arrière
le seul choix qu'on peut faire c'est
décidé c'est l'impact sera positif non
suffit d'arrêter que la machine ou
contrôler et de reprendre le contrôle
sur la machine merci
[Applaudissements]